and speaking of elections
let's take a look at what's happening in
arizona right
there have been all kinds of revelations
from the state of arizona this week with
the ongoing ballot audit that began
in april
now in its fifth
month
everything is a total secret
but
earlier this week actually on monday a
magistrate judge in arizona said hey
republicans actually karen fan arizona
republican senate president
you
have to turn over
all of the documents all of the
communications that you have about this
ongoing ballot audit to the groups who
have sued
one of them being the media outlet
arizona republic
they have a right to have this
information
and now you have senate republicans
desperately fighting and openly defying
this court order
to turn over their communications about
the ballot audit
here's what they're looking for
quote any and all records with a
substantial nexus to the audit are
public records the judge says this
includes
all communications related to planning
the audit policies and procedures of the
audit and all records disclosing who is
paying for the audit and how much is
being spent
that seems pretty innocuous to me right
i mean we're not talking about turning
over the government's files on area 51
folks we're talking about hey
how is this being paid for and how'd
y'all come up with the plan and what's
going on with it
that's it
that's literally what these groups are
wanting to find out and the judge says
this stuff should be public record it's
supposed to be public record you gotta
release it and fan says no i'm not gonna
do it
this is private this i guess is personal
this entire audit from the start as i'm
sure everyone watching this understands
this has been a farce it is absolute
political theater you have had
republicans from other states come in
tour the facility where they were
initially doing the ballot audit so they
could take the blueprints essentially
back to their own states we also know
that cyber ninjas the group conducting
the audit uh basically broke the voting
machines
now costing the the voters in arizona
three million dollars because oops cyber
ninjas accidentally got a bunch of
malware installed in the voting machines
i'm sorry this is this is a terrible
terrible threat to our democracy
but it's also kind of hilarious at how
incompetent these individuals are
and now of course cyber ninjas wants to
get their hands on the routers
as if that's really going to tell them
much of anything um cyber security
experts agree
that the routers really are going to be
you know you're not going to get
anything on that you would have had to
have done it at the time
you know after the fact
you're you're not going to have any data
stored there most likely so
if you wanted that you should have done
it as things were happening so you could
have done the captures which didn't
happen
so there's that
then of course
this is all by the way in the span of
just two weeks a lot of it happening
this week so you've got the republicans
fighting to keep everything secret they
don't want anybody to know what's
happening and gee i wonder why that is
and then you also have republicans
subpoenaed
both dominion voting systems
and
maricopa county officials
wanting even more information to hand
over to cyber ninjas and the maricopa
county folks said listen the stuff
you're asking us for we can't turn it
over one because we don't even have it
it's not our stuff you're asking for
something that other
other uh state entities have so we can't
even do it but two if we did have it we
still wouldn't do it because what you're
asking for includes social security
numbers of our voters
you know all of this vital private
information that if leaked could
absolutely
result in a living nightmare for these
individuals so yeah we don't have it so
we can't give it to you but if we did
have it we wouldn't give it to you we're
not complying with this subpoena we've
complied with everything else you have
everything you need from us
go away at this point is basically what
they're saying and dominion you know
came back with similar things we've
given you everything dominion says
anything else you ask for at this point
is ridiculous
just like by the way this entire ballot
audit is folks
i have no doubt and i have said this
plenty of times you know over on my
youtube channel at fair and balanced and
at ring of fire
if they had found anything at all
anything
a single instance of fraud
they would be coming out holding press
conference saying ladies and gentlemen
the investigation is ongoing but i want
to highlight this
this case of fraud here that we found
that had gone unnoticed this is why the
ballot alderman they haven't done that
because they have nothing to do that for
you also by the way a member of the
senate's appointed audit team the leader
of it came out and said oh we found 74
000
uh ballots
mail out ballots that we have no record
of sending out
and then reporters actually looked at
the record and immediately said actually
there is a record of all of these going
out you're straight up lying to us now
so they're openly lying
they're hiding the information
and there's no signs of this thing going
away anytime soon it's been going on for
five months
and apparently it is just going to keep
on rolling
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get fifty percent off
your first month when you go to
steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video